mi spiego le regole del gioco o famo
strano c'è un capitano c'è il capitano è
molto bravo e morto a posto dice vi sono
partito al proprio galeone è lo scopo
della squadra e andare sul galeone
avversario e tirare su tutta l'ancora il
primo team che tira tuel ancora
avversaria vincente ognuno si può mazza
navale tutto la regola è solo il
pagamento di base nel senso solo cibo
assi palle di cannone
niente esplosivi o cose fiammeggianti
perché ovviamente il nostro scopo non è
affondata in anima si partì alla
cannonata che spariamo dal galeone in
modo che così se c'è un via io rimango
dietro per forza per due motivi uno
perché sono allora i ragazzi non ho la
spada il fucile cecchino milioni ebraico
il cecchino e li becker eco con il
camion con le cannonate che me la cavo
nostra regola posiamo 20 non dobbiamo
affrontare all'avversaria non dobbiamo
fondare la vittoria piegando nave non
sulla nave c'è una realtà di vita che io
vi illustro quando tu cerchi la gente su
sirtis normalmente non la trovi adesso
che non ci serve gente arriverà di tutto
questa una realtà proprio la vita che
facevo anche quindi siccome c'è uno
sloop dietro di noi che facciamo non
viene è sicuro ti facevo e io mentre ti
facevo questo discorso non l'avevo mica
una spina con la benzina del mio editore
a simetti dovremmo allevare le bandiere
dei fatti sto andando a toglierla rega
tirare sull'anca del riciclo ancora no
però c'è simone non guariti se possibile
9 giro e le canzoni a muro
lei come solo noi sappiamo fare questo
altrove siano girati non capiscono che
devono andarsene glielo facciamo capire
mi sparo la bandiera dell'alleanza io mi
sono tuffato cercherò di tali a bordo
visto salendo a bordo non stanno girando
che dovrei prenderli me non avete fecero
church ecco che in coppa ma noi abbiamo
fatto capire madonna gli ho fatto
esplodere la coppa lei visto o mio dio
la tv madonna che che può donna che
sotto fatto è preso il barile raga
pazzesco gli squali sclosa tutta tu hai
fatto saltare una donna volta ma no
ragazzi mi pare corazzato gli ho fatto
una madonna è stato bellissimo a livello
scelto ma ti giuro madonna che casino ho
fatto mi sa che sono affondati pronti
che fanno la partita perché si è partita
la prima di becchi pure è partita
partita avara titolo giocavo in difesa
se sia sparati recava del film ma il
canone lo posso usare per buttarli giù
no no no no spero si possa sparare
adesso a questo occhio si alza di un
salvagente ucciso ha ucciso i loro
stanno un in meno ma perché lo può
vedere spanò e che c'entra però il sito
14 insieme a quello dobbiamo fare in
realtà no allora fa una cosa seria
sono solo testato ecco non possiamo
sparare l'altra nave ok ma da quando ci
deve dire un attimo fa una cosa non è
già iniziata a iniziata post ho colpito
uno che saltella ha colpito da una volta
cacchio è molto giusto la casa un morto
ecco allora la cosa che secondo me ci
dobbiamo mettere tutti quei fucili da
cecchino e cecchinelli dal dalla numero
cala mezzo noi dobbiamo cecchinare lì
praticamente ucciso vento grigio o
colpito e ucciso
vai vai vai vai vai inchinate occhi ho
visto salire 1 preso quale canzone è
buono l'ultimo a sinistra era abbassare
un pochettino a girare un po più a
destra ma cosa dobbiamo fare la caso la
loro nave ma ancora c'è uno sotto adesso
casa c'era il ground rega bravo o di chi
bravissimo
bravo ci occorre parma gianni fabbri
murduch anni non ho ricordi quando
prendere colpi loro bravo di tutti a
occhio dice slippino scesa fino a occhio
che è morto solo uno di loro non ho due
cioè scappino qui e non muore è quasi
morto ma non muore sapinho tirato
miliardo come ha fatto a non morire gli
ha sparato due volte come facciamo
dobbiamo rifarla tattica the primate fa
il check in da sopra allora si copre le
spalle a due che salgono ok
vai ma l'aspetta io mi occupo allora se
io pure sto col pompa infatti c'è uno
qua barbagianni né scorso ho peccato
barbagianni che era nascosta in mezzo
all'erba ci si aspettava uccisa venni
belli belli
madonna è difficilissimo però uno
sparava dover baciare e ho capito c'è
stata barbagianni quindi sta qua sotto
16 maggio ammazzarlo l'acqua sotto
l'acqua ma da loro ma noi da noi da noi
noi tutto da noi
io vedo solo lo squalo perché non c'è
nessuno
di morte eccola qua ha ucciso uno è
andato nostra nel mezzo
l'evento grigio sotto in coperta c'è
dentro la nostra è la nostra nave nostra
nave sarà nella loro ce ne sono due
barbagianni dettato madonna mi ha dato
il cuore non muore ragazza e barbagianni
ma fattore campo
no ma ho ucciso pure a me raga però
giura che è tutto nelle tue mani la tela
io sono visto che lo difende solo di
ferrara posto va bene io sono la nostra
arma prega quindi abbiamo perso mst si
sappia che ci mettete in mente una vita
va bene e da sola perché è un ragazzo
forte la sua faccia era impossibile non
arrivò questo noto anche in un metro da
in cm d'acqua
oggi lanciare con i cannoni serenità la
loro nave
se perdiamo è colpa solo uguale ma forse
la giorni stone già vinto lega hanno già
vinto a desio cesano suonando che
giocata ciò non che ha fondato la barca
no scherzi no di scena affronta barca
appena fatto ha giocato già si è giocato
ma non è la sola maniera anche malvagio
anni
poi parlando di ammazzati tutti con una
cappellina
keira knightley complimenti appelli cgg
sparisce
questo è quello che succede nella nostra
barca per madonna che ho beccato in volo
io in voluto bene che ho lanciato una
bomba in aria mi sento addosso ti giuro
completamente juncker 11 pronti quando
vuoi c'è un gay one war 3 non spareranno
subito come era il tiro preciso io sopra
ligure sta sopra un è morto
tiriamo subito ritirati reti record in
via roma via no c'è scappino io sto
continuando dai la qualcuno mi
chiamarono come una mano ognuno vai dai
venere nera dai pirati tirate fate laga
qua tutto sotto controllo
dai dai dai dai dai dai line
tg amico subito la ricoh loro madonna
guarda faringei dato ai madonna ragioni
che giocata cacchio contro gente che
gioca da tre anni ha studiato da giocare
con gente perché sapete esattamente come
mettere il cannone per farmi finire una
lava in unico lo sappiamo
[Musica]
no